en France aujourd'hui si on regarde
globalement le le montant total
d'épargne c'est plus de 5000 milliards
la dette est pratiquement à 3000
milliards l'assurance vie c'est 1875
milliards
c'est important de protéger les
épargnants parce que il y a un principe
de base c'est que les Français
lorsqu'ils épargnent aujourd'hui
malheureusement ils perd d'une partie du
fruit de leur épargne par des un manque
de transparence des frais un peu cachés
et surtout qui s'accumulent donc l'idée
c'est payer moins et gagner plus c'est à
dire que sur les sommes qui sont versées
évidemment il y ait moins de
prélèvements pour faire en sorte que
l'envie d'épargne pour nourrir
l'économie réelle et productive soit
encouragées au service du redressement
et du de l'économie productive de notre
pays encouragez l'épargne c'est faire en
sorte que le maximum d'argent puisse
être bien utilisé avec une efficacité et
puis évidemment la contrepartie quand on
confie son argent c'est d'avoir une
rémunération intéressante et qui
encourage à ce à ce devoir dépendre
nous avons souhaité rendre systématique
et donc obligatoire ce qu'on appelle la
transférabilité interne des contrats
d'assurance vie au sein d'une même
compagnie d'assurance et puis et aussi
le fait de proposer que la
transférabilité d'un contrat d'assurance
vie entre une compagnie a et une
compagnie B devienne possible à nous
avons mis par contre une condition c'est
au delà des 8 premières années puisque
dans ce temps des 8 premières années on
a une enveloppe fiscale une antériorité
qu'il faut absolument finalement
protéger ensuite nous souhaitons ouvrir
la possibilité de pouvoir changer de
compagnie pour répondre aux besoins soit
nouveaux soit aux attentes ici d'un
intermédiaire là de changement de
formule de produits voilà pour redonner
à la fois de la fluidité mettre de la
concurrence et stimuler là encore cette
envie d'épargne de nos concitoyens
plutôt que une forme de
d'assouplissement de léthargie de
conservatisme c'est au contraire de
réveiller les envies d'avoir une épargne
dynamique qui à la fois soutien et
encourage le développement économique
mais aussi qui rémunère celui ou celle
qui prend un risque en la confiance pour
financer l'économie ça fait gagner la
France